calculus big topic yeah but you guys
have been doing pretty well I think
capturing all the different ideas but
I've been saying all along like that we
start off slow and we're sort of
gradually increasing the numbers of
kinds of functions that we can deal with
differentiate okay so today we're moving
past rege well we look completely past
that we will keep on working with it
well we're gonna introduce new function
families now by the way you like man it
took like three hours just to do one
trig function and today we're not just
gonna do expeditions we're gonna do the
logs are you nuts
I'm not well maybe I am but no for this
reason exponential as long as they do go
together because really they're just two
sides are the same for you okay and I
promise it will actually be very very
much regard to derive these results all
right so we'll start with Exponential's
then we'll use that result prove the
long run but it'll go like that now what
are we gonna start with is an
exponential function
okay so let's consider y equals two to
the X before I launch it - all over need
agree to technical stuff right just as
we treat let's just a placid intuition
to this okay it's just to think about
what does to the X look like what's an
expansion right so it starts to be close
to the axis and then so I just walk it
off like so okay so if you want to
describe its gradient because that's
much more bizarre how would you describe
it what number one
it's always an increasing function I've
been talking about this sort of on and
off increasing and decreasing just being
up or down but this is let me add
another word into this account this is
not just increasing it's monotonic
increasing its like this topic is all
about long words monotonically means
that's all it ever dies like monotone
right like a person who speaks in the
same turn all the time this function is
always increasing okay so that's like
for monotonically increasing but it's
not always increasing the same rate how
do you describe how much it's increasing
oh snap okay excited so let's take this
idea right if I could represent this
visually right over here I'm increasing
what I'm increasing super super salon
right so it's like plus a little bit
really tiny sort of increases over here
but as you get further along you like
okay I'm increasing some more and some
more and the further you go
exponentially is exactly if I were
actually because it keeps getting
steeper and it keeps getting steeper
forever never slows down
okay so just on basis of intuition we
would say this exponential function its
gradient function it also seems to be
exponential does that make sense seems
to follow exactly the same room all
right now do you every trick right we
said we applied some intuition what was
that next step after that to tread test
our intuition what we do first
principles that's right so to the X to
the yes what would it look like if we
used first bits do you wire the X would
be equal to how does a little bit start
a spritz of stop with the limit concern
spoilers all right what are we go to the
top f of X plus h f of X plus h if F is
to the X
yeah the raising that extra touch that's
my pal okay minus f of X which is just
this okay then you divide through by H
which is the rise over run all right so
if I so you could know what go to call
them fat to heal and you grate up right
to the X here this is actually really to
the expert H is really short hand for to
the X x to the edge notice that remember
Enix laws okay
so therefore I'm gonna take my factor e
to the X out okay now before I do that
I'm not just here to take out the front
faction okay because to the X we've done
this before entry has nothing to do with
H okay I'm just going to be completely
out of a living so I've got to get all
the way out front and then the limit as
H approaches 0 of to the edge minus 1
okay yeah at this point we are rather
stuck because that's fine but what is
this thing well is it busy to look like
okay and that's why I brought my
computer today okay I was hoping you had
your computer with you and that you
could actually follow along at home and
I will show a little bit about
spreadsheets except for except for you
guys were experts as pictures there but
you're gonna have to since post it most
of you do not have your laptop's here
you're just gonna have to